[Music]
as Dr Ferguson makes his incision y'all
give me my Robin Lee's voice you're
gonna narrate this thing
you're concentration in the bone surgery
I get a little Point get a little
stressed in that sometimes but yo
orders I can see you in like come you
repeat and you keep moving I don't know
if you just really respecting what I'm
doing are you afraid I'm gonna ask you
to help I don't like bones you very
studious and you love them being heavy
glasses down here like screws
we've been playing this for about 20
plus here 20 plus I know when to leave
you alone and when is that
when you really concentrating on that I
don't want to get quiet right or you
drink some milk
[Laughter]
among the flurry of furry friends at the
clinic is a patient with a returning
problem
sorry Milani is a six-year-old Doberman
we had her since she was a puppy she's
been walking around without putting
pressure on her back leg this is
actually her second time around with the
same issue there was some movement
between the knee joints Dr Ferguson
ended up operating on her and fixing it
but she's coming across the same problem
again hello hello
[Music]
I know that man right there I see her
trying to fake it and like put her leg
down even though she hasn't put weight
on it she's trying to tell you I'm all
right hey it's okay come on well I can
see what's going on how long it's been I
said about two weeks now
she's been lifting her legs she's
staying off of it not even want to put
it down not at all okay let me put a
hand on the back here you want to switch
with the drier she was crying a lot
which is just heartbreaking do we know
that she did something active and Bam it
just happened all of a sudden she's
active she likes to play catch play
fetch I'm crazy about it I like it I
know because I want an X right here okay
and see if we see any pathology changes
in there and really kind of feel and see
if I can feel anything
I actually repaired lunch right ACL
anterior Crusade ligament two years ago
with a prosthetic and being lame on that
same leg is not good Alana is a very
active dog so there is a possibility
that she's Towing the prosthetic
Doberman they're also prone to having
issues with the hip your X-ray for
Lonnie is up
we definitely got a lot of arthritic
changes in here like everywhere but they
do look inflamed up in this area right
in here it could have been running and
slipping towards some fibers tissue
something's wrong with the ACL Clips we
put in the last time too I think she
probably torn and click but that clip
really should be going from here to
there not going that way so that tail
that thing is broken the orientation of
my clip is not where it should be which
kind of cluing me in and that we may
have a torn prosthetic and that torn
prosthetic not holding the knee and
making it stable which is causing a lot
of extra osteoarthritis inflammation and
Bone and it's definitely painful I think
I feel a click that would tell me we may
have some meniscal injury yeah it's
gonna be a 30k so I guess we need to get
them scheduled we probably have some
meniscal damage which makes it a lot
tougher with the instability with the
osteoarthritis left untreated a lot I
may never use this leg again looking at
this sniff we do have some instability
in there which tells me that the
prosthetic has broken we need to go back
in that knee we need to go and take this
out and then replace that line that we
had in
while we're in there I can also repair
the meniscus as well so it's just
probably in a lot of pain if there's
some pain yes but it's more
uncomfortableness and I just learned
just to hold it up and not even put it
down now it's always a little
challenging the second time around we're
old enough things take longer to heal up
than they did two years ago so it's
still going to be a process so there's
no way around it we have to do surgery
yeah
you know it gets tough you know when you
have to go back in a second time because
the owners have been through this
process and when you're doing an ACL
repair it's not like doing a spay in
three or four days and everything is
finally back to normal this is a long
process of recovering you know going
through therapy and getting the animals
sounding back and she's upset about
having to do it again you know because
that's her baby it's kind of ripping out
her heart a little bit it's going to be
a challenging surgery but we're going to
go ahead and get this repaired so we can
make this baby better and that's what I
aim to do
damn it
Solani is like our own kid so it's very
emotional especially for my wife you
want to see your own kid feel better so
now it's going through it again two
years later the emotions got to her
again about what we may expect with
Lonnie after the surgery
foreign
[Music]
hey Harley we brought Harley and Goldie
we brought him in to have Harley Jack
squares pulling his feathers and both of
them had to have their nails clipped
their Jen day Conyers brother and sister
they're 20 years old we've raised them
from babies hey what's up everybody you
all right yes I'm fine how you doing my
friend all right I'm doing great on your
shoulder though the birds get on my
shoulder in the mornings I get on the
computer and look up mail put a puzzle
together Goldie gets in my shirt I'm
glad that she spends the time with him
she does gives me a lot of free time
don't die what's up she's been pulling
her feathers for a couple years she
stopped laying eggs a couple of years
ago in our caves a lot of toys
not really I mean she's never played
with toys okay this one plays with juice
tops and rolls them everywhere what do
you find that this one is interested in
just looking out the window just looking
out in the window we gotta get you more
excitement hey I like the computer I
don't know if we can put a
fly anymore really so cause you can't
fly that way
see we got some yeast on that skin she
looks like a Cornish hen
Chucky for a little yeast and bacteria
and see so
and birds have opportunistic pathogens
on their skin I mean it's normal
bacterial floral but when we get an
overgrowth the animal will start
clicking or scratching worst case
scenario opportunistic pathogens get
down to the hair follicles and gets into
the blood and makes it septic which
could ultimately lead to a bird's death
hey I say that too when I see here when
I see that guy right there I do the same
thing screaming over there being with
you man
has been totally quiet until you you
love me
I think it was a heck no you get a
little swamp birds have a crop that's
kind of where they have their food you
can see the actual swab moving in the
crop not at first you um official swab
holder that end came from the mouth now
I'm going to the other end you hold the
other end it's very important that check
both ends the crop the oral cabinet and
also check the back end the anus area
there's so many possible passages that
could be proliferating in this animal so
we definitely want to be very thorough
so then we don't miss anything all right
Bird nice and easy sometimes less is
more so I take a piece of tape and put
it on the bird can you see that I'm
gonna look for some fungus on it put it
on my slide and once we check the slide
that lets me know if there's yeast of
bacteria on there so I can get out of
that cage if I want to yes I can okay so
it depends how you look at it I got good
news and bad news good news there's no
physical problems with this bird no
bacteria or fungus none on the chest and
none in a co-worker and it's just that's
kind of bad news because that tells me
it's up here just a habit it's just like
it just burns like the rest of America
like all of us it's just it's just
anxiety maybe it's trying to find some
toys but I am going to try some groovy
grape flavored diazepam and see if we'll
take that feather plug in this
psychological I mean kind of like me I
chew my nails I try not to but sometimes
I will a lot of times these guys get
bored it's messed with all the people at
home with their animals more people
getting anxiety birds get anxiety good
old anxiety medicine typically Works how
many times a day oh that feels good I
want you to kind of watch and see how we
tend to do oh no in the meantime I'm
gonna cut his nails well I appreciate it
thank you I thought Dr Hodges was going
to tell me that Harley had cancer or
something that was you know terribly
wrong with her but it was all in her
hair I think it started off not being
able to lay eggs and hatch eggs you know
that's their purpose in life yes like
birdie menopause we should be good to go
for a 20-year bird looks fantastic
thank you no problem I adore these birds
they are my heart I just want them to
have a good healthy life and be able to
enjoy them as long as possible and then
they end up outliving us
[Music]
Jordan you got the whole body you need
my help Superwoman continuing their busy
day Dr Ferguson and his team prepare to
re-repair Lonnie's ACL sit down baby
girl I know it hurts going in for a
second time can be very difficult
because things don't quite heal back
like they are initially there's a lot of
scar tissue there's a lot of
inflammation they don't look the same
when they did the first time all right
ready
relax on this wall to take a deep breath
and get prepared mentally you always
mentally we're prepared my zen moment
here
how you put the bread deep breaths
breathing in slow hold it and then count
to four breathing out
[Music]
and I'm bringing it back
this is the first time you know I've had
this breathing treatment prior to
surgery I think it might be working you
know it's allowed me to open up my third
eye you know so I can make sure I'm
successful because I'm gonna need all
three of them in this surgery you know
what I feel better Jordan it helps
you ready get this old knee fixed up
again so the game plan is to open up
find and remove the old prosthetic get
this knee cleaned out as best we can
replace and put a new prosthetic in and
try to stabilize this knee so that we
can be just as good as new but it all
depends on how bad this knee is once we
open it up
we do something different since you did
it before no we're gonna do it the same
let me see if I can find my prosthetic
in here there it is come on out of here
buddy
oh wow when this prosthetic was torn the
fibrous tissue probably did hold a joint
stable for a while until it stretched
because it had a lot of force on it but
let's see we need to look for this woman
let's consider I see it with a meniscus
and flipped all the way up whoa because
that meniscus is flipped it's almost
like if you had something in your sock
every time you step down it's causing
discomfort so we have to repair the
damaged meniscus before I perform the
ACA repair so we have a nice flat
surface so that doesn't cause a lot of
stress when we flexing and extending
osteoarthritis in here it's terrible let
me call it boogered up that's the best
word I can use that meniscus is in bad
shape if I can't repair it's meniscus
it's going to cause a lot of pain which
is going to cause London not to use this
leg again
all kind of stuff going on didn't he
they have damage to the meniscus and
that's what I'm doing now removing some
of this meniscal tissue here so I've
never seen you clean that much out this
is definitely far from a simple ACL
repair I'm hoping that down the trick I
think a little bit of that clicking is
going to feel better yeah so let's see
if we can replace the prosthetic doing
the extra capsule repair I will use a
special leader line and we run it in a
figure eight position that's close to
the alignment of the original ACL good
that's good right now now let's try this
leg out
all right pretty good oh yeah I feel
better now that during clicking and
grinding we had for sure awesome job it
looks great that's probably the toughest
repair of hand calls we've been in that
joint before there was some Municipal
damage that we had to repair and we
replaced those Prosthetics yeah me and
the dog done I think I'm feeling pretty
comfortable after second surgery that
everything is going to work out you want
to not overuse the leg I think
everything's going to be fine it's going
to be a long process of recovery
hey hey how'd it go
everything went good it's definitely a
challenge the second time through but we
got in and got out so one of the
prostated pizza was broken so that it
got it stable again and we also had
meniscal damage I think that's why I'm
gonna start the issue was coming from
now we're just gonna have to take it
easy I want to be on a leash for the
majority attack no running around right
because what will happen is we go
outside and here come the squirrel we'll
take off and then we'll be back while we
started I'll be checking during that
time and kind of let you know when we
release but probably at least two months
okay be right back okay all right
my wife and I relieved after talking
with Dr Ferguson it'll be a change at
least for the next couple of months
we'll have to keep her on the leash
until she gets better not so much
letting her out like she used to come on
girl slow it down slow it down that's
right slow down now we just talked to
Mommy about that she's always active
it's going to be a change for her for
sure look we brought Lonnie back
[Music]
all right thank you give me a hug yes
ma'am you need anything let us know okay
thank you
the Critter fixers head to a farm to
give a group of kids a unique view of
what vets do on the job
[Music]
So today we're at Coal Creek Ranch we're
gonna have kids who are from the inner
city they've never been on the farm so
I'm super excited only two percent of
veterinarians are black veterinarians so
we're hoping being two guys that are
doing anything you can be cool to them
what y'all think about being on the farm
and cops are they cool all right first
of all I saw everybody when he walked up
y'all looking at me and looking straight
ahead you gotta look at the ground you
know why cow chip you know what the cow
chip is
a good name yeah the name of the
organization is fathers among men we
work with fathers in the community doing
a lot of different activities for
fathers day to bring their kids out
anytime you can get kids out to get a
new experience give them freedom and
they get to learn about a lot of things
we love giving them new experiences
that's what it's all about y'all see the
baby so sometimes we want to figure out
if there's a baby on this side anybody
having any idea how we do it
put your hand in the back come here you
like you've done this before so you're
gonna you're gonna check one out for me
today
[Music]
but that exactly right these are gloves
how far you think those gloves go by
right here
yeah I don't want no glue sometimes we
have to get down and dirty keep going
I'm right here
I see it an appreciation for what we
have to do it's your second chance of
this kid yeah last time I had for my son
BJ out here and you know I was trying to
teach him how to do it keep going you
ain't hitting the cow if it's big you
could almost bounce the head like a
basketball I'm feeling serious but this
time we're gonna have Old Uncle fur get
in here in the shoot with VJ all right
let's go
you gotta tell her to relax relax please
there you go
close your eyes and feel
I feel like I'm in here I feel like it's
on top of my hand though like above well
you got to make a call bro you have 50
50 cents for being right okay then close
then pregnant yeah we'll say bread live
bread okay all right now let me see if
you're lying or not
I got your back man
check out old man
BJ what'd you say Ray good job BJ fish
is definitely getting better I can
definitely see Improvement oh he
actually got it right you know he'll
learn a little bit of me and he'll learn
a little bit from this guy so just to
create affects the way to teach
everybody and do the best we can we
don't have any more clothes
everybody else want a pal face
[Music]
we change y'all country folks it's easy
to reading the book about a farm but
when you stand in the middle of a pastor
and you seeing cows walking around I
mean it's amazing so we will definitely
provide this opportunity more kids what
you think have you ever touched the cow
no my favorite part about being out here
is when I got to see him palpitate the
cow it was amazing all out slowly yeah
yeah the vests were cool they joked
around we had fun the cows I got the
feed I pet a horse today was a good day
oh cool my girls I want to be a pony
helper
to have ponies when they're sick they
having a great time this is all about
learning we expose the youth to it early
enough and they maybe walk to you and Dr
Ferguson's uh footsteps we're hoping so
we thank y'all for having us thank you
all man thank you I appreciate it
[Music]
hey what's up hi how you been good
today we brought our goats Jack and
Piper to get their vaccinations they are
12 weeks old they're Nigerian dwarf
quotes my wife wanted goats for pets so
I ended up getting them for I like both
of them because one's playful and one's
cuddly today they're going to get their
clostridium with Texas in and we're
gonna take care of the Family Jewels
use the people don't laugh when I say
that as long as I stay away from you
right yeah you don't take care of them
they get stinky they get stinky they do
if you do not fix goats they tend to pee
on themselves in their face because
that's how they attract the female goats
because we want to love on them and
cuddle them so we do not want them to do
that you don't want stinky Goats No they
smell good no no well I know they ain't
quite got that nice gold Aroma you
wouldn't do the vaccine yeah I'll do the
vaccine it is very important for young
girls to get their vaccines because
their immune system is very prone to
more illnesses we're gonna get these
babies vaccinated against clostridium
and tetanus which is a bigger harmful
bacteria that is found in the soils so
we want to make sure these guys are safe
to go out and just be known for playful
happy goats so this one is deck Jack all
right
all done with the easy injection part
got a little prison freezer
what kind of present you want we're
gonna band Jack yes so Batman is a
painless non-invasive procedure you put
on these elastic bands and it actually
works over time and the testicles
eventually fall off sometimes we use
this as opposed to surgically removing
the testicles
easy for you to say
and the most important thing once we
pull them through we make sure we get
these teeth out the way
I don't want to get too much when we put
elastic band you just want to make sure
you put it on properly because anything
that that band is on is actually going
to constrict if you include the teeth
inside of that elastic band those teeth
are definitely going to die and you're
gonna have a whole different problem
[Music]
it's okay it's over yeah
you my friend have been banded hyper
it's a little bit more nervous where's
my good friend he loves banding about
like he likes chickens oh I'll be right
back guys okay anybody seeing Dr
Ferguson yeah he just went that way
what's up what's going on I figure that
bring a tool out for you
[Music]
look
you don't ever do that if I'm on this
side of the tube
no I'm actually holding too
don't come over here Paul he trying to
take your man he who holds this tool is
in command so I'm the king of the castle
right now you're better than the king
you know who you are you're the king you
have that one level King
what you got I got a cute little gold in
here I'm gonna let you have the honor so
I am presenting you the two hold on I
might need to do this
[Music]
I've been presenting you to painting too
thank you let me be on this side yeah
you got to be on this side all right
let's go all right let's see if we can
make this thing work here I know how you
love banding I think you just want me to
do dirty work if that's what I think it
is man it's always one worse band in the
goats or examine the chicken you know
how I am with chickens but this banding
thing is kind of hit a little close to
home just Ted just a little closer home
so I definitely feel these little guys
make it a little squirmy yeah definitely
locks for me you let me know how you
want to hold oh no
what's up keep you company
it's like you don't know what's gonna
happen to you brother he's like run yeah
you're pretty strong now that's a good
kick you got girl
this might be a little tough all right
let's see if we can make something
happen here
[Music]
buddy just calm down
no your brother was a champ or maybe it
was a doctor too that could have hey he
could have been a dollar
so T I know you a gentle giant and nice
and delicate but oh V quick on a drop
man I doubt it but look you know I think
you got Advantage Harper got a warning
signal from the other baby I mean like
ah nah
don't you going to sleep
and goat charmer to my thing hey hey I'm
sleeping I am the goat Whisperer
it's over yeah good to go yes we are
yours is almost as good enough
yeah without you it wouldn't work bro
yeah hey one thing about it yes I think
we're the best banding duo in the state
of Georgia you've done it right they're
the best looking too I think so
they look fantastic you guys have some
amazing goats I think good to see as
always there good to see you I wasn't
sure how they were going to react
especially Jack but actually he did
better than Piper did Piper was a little
bit more nervous but they did great it
went well we appreciate everything that
Dr Hodges does for us so we'll be
bringing them back for their checkups
from now on
Dr Hodges Paul and Vijay are suited up
to visit a local koi rescue those are
real clay you don't see it nowhere else
did they ever make you all an art class
make them little pots and stuff uh the
red clay yep that was really good old
days getting that stuff is getting the
clothes he said that's how I know you
don't go outside enough so I've lost
hard enough to know what red clay is you
know what it is but you ain't got it all
in your clothes it's all over my shoes I
got a pair outside shoes with correctly
on DJ you ever put some wild plums
maybe I am raising you right
[Music]
hey y'all hello how are you I'm sorry
how you doing come out I love it amazing
setup this is
how are you nice to meet you she is
starting to be a vet as well yes for
fishing these some smart good people so
looking forward to you joining thank you
since 2015 we've rescued between three
and four thousand koi most of these koi
have been abandoned they've been on
properties so we get them we bring them
here we get them better as best we can
and they move on to a better life there
are a lot of people who believe that you
can't love them and you absolutely can I
love my fish they look great you guys
are doing amazing job oh thank you come
on over here you in the bedside come on
I want to kind of look at this guy this
one has a melanoma
we have recently had a rescue that was
just far beyond our normal capabilities
we had great concerns
I don't know with a massive black spot
when I touched it it bled I don't like
that part was starting to come up and
get under the skin and so it's really
it's lifting the scales up are you
thinking of cutting out oh yeah we'll
see if we can get that out you want to
assist me and put a sleep a fish on the
anesthesia I would love to today I'm
thinking let's go ahead and surgical
remove this melanoma it's not going to
actually cure the cancer but it
definitely will give this fish a better
quality of life
we're gonna take the water out of here
and then we're going to recirculate it
okay she's about to add our fish
anesthesia here what's that stuff that
you're putting in the water
clove oil which is what I use for
anesthesia it's an essential oil from
the clove plant it just an exercises the
fish so it just goes down and goes to
sleep I found that it keeps the fish in
a correct anesthetic plane all right
let's grab our fish what's this fish
name cancer
let's see if we can change their name
what you want to do is go back and forth
right
you're right we get intubated and we
breathe
a fish don't exactly have lungs with
fish we gotta make sure we got water
that has anesthesia in it and so we're
just running across the Gill trying to
keep it to where it kind of drains back
down in there I think I just jumped in
she's giving my anesthesia so she's
basically my anesthesiologist so we're
just prepping it and cleaning up
yeah it's a deep melanoma that's how
deep that is
yeah I'm just taking it off how I'm
doing parking good just keeping these
gills moist going pretty deep because
this melanoma is actually pretty deep in
this case we're going to take as much as
we can so it's not upon that scale
you almost done Paul is he starting to
come up from anesthesia slightly all
right you almost hit me up you trying to
rush me that fella Paul don't talk a lot
but when Paul says doc uh we need to
wrap this up thing I need to get this
fish up off of this surgery table so I
just want to make sure I get as much as
the middle of them out of here as I can
I'm gonna need a few minutes
you need to hurry up doc just give me a
little bit longer fishing
I'm probably gonna be about a minute
away below when I live a little bit I'm
about to how I just need to hurry up BJ
come here my left pocket is some
antibiotics there let me show you how we
give antibiotics so the caulifin and the
anus is where we get those what we call
IP injections so we're gonna do a 45
degree angle you just go right directly
in to the abdomen okay and you put in
that'll help recover a lot faster we're
ready to transport a cover tank ready
it's ready sir covered
so you just keep swimming until he wakes
up yes ma'am back and forth right so
nice and easy all right so right here so
because we want everything to go through
the gills doing that for a little while
longer
welcome back buddy
I can breathe a sour relief cancer came
through uh surgery really well then
starting to recover my trusted assistant
helped me here and uh maybe we'll name
this fish cure it now let's go over I
test a test
when we initially was getting cancer out
of the pond we noticed that one fish had
a huge ulcer so we actually gonna
deliver some antibiotic into a
peritoneum I taught her exactly where
we're supposed to give the injection so
you got a perfect shot so this is your
antibiotic oh hello
I'm gonna hold them what degree angle 45
45 here you go okay we're gonna turn
them up just a little perfect okay go up
under our scale up under a scale yep
perfect going deliver your antibiotics
you're done okay good job thank you when
Dr Hodges tells me that I'm going to be
helping I was a little nervous but I
knew that he needed me so I you know
kind of pushed down that anxiety and I
made sure to be there for him having him
allow me to be a part of the process it
was just really great and I was very
appreciative can she get an internship
down there of course you can we got her
cover
I'm very grateful because Dr Hodges and
being a good fish expert and he's like
here's what we got to do right here now
the fish had a little little chance and
now he has a good fighting chance and we
are going to be renaming him pure so we
have great hope for this fish at this
point you got amazing operation I mean
it's brilliant it's needed and you
pleasure yeah thank you soon I'll be
able to retire yep all right thank you
all so much for having us thank you
don't get ready too fast don't let us
rush it just stand here looking we're
chilling might be a singing Duo what do
you think I can't say
that's all I can do
so we background yeah we background I
tend to get ready for surgery very
quickly so while the techs are prepping
the patient I like to prep the surgery
team with the best free medicine that
they can get Ferguson's freestyle Jordan
you can see we'll be Jordan Howard and
the Pips don't do that to me don't do it
to you come on
my knee is getting too old for
let's get this done first before I go
down I love it
you're a wild rabbit you don't look like
a rabbit I've seen running around my
yard a Good Samaritan comes to the
clinic with a rabbit in need of urgent
care I'll just see crush the ears back
[Music]
I was out cleaning the front yard and
noticed so the corner of my eye
something popping in the yard and they
saw it hop again so I walked over and
they're sure enough was a bunny hiding
under the tree then noticed he wasn't
well his ear looked horrible and then we
noticed it's got awful wound and I
cleaned it up and then I thought okay
this is really really bad I gotta get
him in ASAP let's see what's going on
there's an ear infection I can see you
can see all the crusties oh boy what'd
you see doc a pit has pits this moon is
absolutely filled with maggots what
happens oftentimes animal gets a wound
flies lay there are eggs on these wounds
the maggots The larva starts to eat the
flesh they need to give them some heavy
juice give them some happy juice we're
gonna give them a little bit of
something to relax them maggots are kind
of a gift and a curse maggots definitely
eat up all the Flesh and clean that area
up but they also sometimes will die
inside the womb and this causes all
kinds of tissue irritation receptions
and erosions so I need to get these
masks out of this rabbit and out of my
clinic we just had to do this case
before lunch yeah strong stomach now and
for being here this many years
all right y'all gotta get out of my
wound I'm actually using just a water
and a beta9 solution to flush all the
magnets out cheese hey man what's up bro
some creepy crawlers foreign
[Music]
stuff that come in and pits that have
pets oh yeah so you know we always put
them on your schedule is that why I
always eat ing that's exactly why you
throwing tickets online I'm throwing the
maggots on your schedule magnitude of
maggots for you hold up don't be
flinging now you look you like you're
flinging
because that'll be a horrible joke if
you tried to fling one on me the loves
to taste a little crunchy
I think I'm just gonna open this up so I
can really take a good look with the
bride mint what you're doing is cutting
away all the dead stuff and getting to
some good tissue that will actually have
a good blood supply if it doesn't bleed
it don't heal like not hiding up in
there
oh you got another pocket up here
in a deep crevice in the pocket
everywhere man look at that
everywhere
I need to get all of these maggots out
ASAP otherwise this rabbit won't be
hopping around any backyard soon
Maggie's everywhere man everywhere I did
not wake up this morning thinking I was
gonna have to flush creepy crawling
things out of a womb all right baby so I
gotta get out of my womb good thing we
opened it huh yes sir definitely gonna
get all the maggots out the last thing
we want is maggots dying in a wound
trying to get the last of these little
Jokers out
[Applause]
all right I think it's finally safe to
say my wound is Maggie free I won't
actually don't look that bad it really
doesn't smell the maggots did their job
because the tissue is actually pretty
healthy the tissue is nice and pink I'm
actually going to suture it together
we're looking real good this guy had a
couple hundred maggots man so I've
gotten that wound fixed I've gotten all
the maggots out most importantly telling
to work on these ears some nasty ears
buddy you're gonna feel a whole lot
better if you've gotten those ears clean
I feel very comfortable this bun is
going to do great I guess I'm ready for
lunch
I think first come on you smell better
oh
so the maggots actually started here
over here it'll easily a few hundred
more
probably more than that I've got them in
the maggots got them suited up only
missing one thing
I think I'm lucky lucky no no he doesn't
look too lucky right now he's lucky
think about it last night this poor guy
was fending off maggots yeah today he's
going to a nice home new lease on life
wasn't hoping to hear hundreds of
maggots so I'm super thankful somebody
was able to look after him we had a name
lucky because I think we're lucky to
have found him then we were willing to
take him in and it could have been
anybody else and who knows what their
reaction would have been I'm lucky to
have them in our lives and lucky to have
found a doctor who was willing to take
care of them you are good to go thank
you so much I appreciate you so much
thank you no problem
foreign
[Music]
how this baby been doing Lonnie the dog
is back for a checkup after taking some
time to recover from intense knee
surgery so how's therapy been going
she's been using her leg been ticker out
every day okay after her surgery on her
right leg we removed her stitches and Dr
Ferguson has been advising us what to do
what not to do for her Rehabilitation so
we want to start doing a little more
walking okay you can also take a hand
here and just kind of push it out real
slow there and then we're going to bring
it back up I don't know if you can tell
our demeanor she's actually comfortable
oh yes just look at these muscles back
here Lonnie is doing fairly well last
time we had a little atrophy in that leg
through I'm hoping to see that muscle
and kind of getting a little bit bigger
than just see the progress on how we're
doing I can tell we regaining some
muscle mass yes that's what I was
telling you yeah the range of motion you
know that's good there and tell me that
we are using it so what I want to do
let's go outside for a minute let's see
how we move around a little bit let's go
show them your man I'm not expecting to
be running around but I'm hoping to see
Lonnie and putting the leg down a lot
more than we did the last time I'm very
anxious to go ahead and give that all
clear signal easy you're not leaving yet
yeah not yet do your circle thing with
her okay
[Music]
good girl Lonnie
there we go we're doing good great I'm
pleased with where we are keep doing
those circles we're doing good you know
right now to be using as much as we are
hey girl look at that all right Lonnie
we can go back in I think Lonnie's
walking you here and I'm very happy with
where we are that muscle actually that
I'm a little bit concerned about on the
last recheck is getting better which
tells me that we're using that leg a lot
as well which is good so we're
definitely on the road to recovery she
can get back to some of those normal
activities I'm very optimistic and I
feel that we're going to have a full
recovery we're going to keep doing what
we're doing and then other than that
we're good thank you all right all right
thank you all right I'm glad we're doing
good Lonnie's injury and her surgery has
been a long process but Dr Ferguson has
been phenomenal we just still have to
continue with her Rehabilitation but
Lonnie's healing uh real good she's in
good spirits Lani is part of the family
so we'll do anything to put her at ease
for the rest of her life hey a good girl
they need to build me a barn
[Music]
abscess yep I dropped Legacy off this
morning to find out why she had an
abscess on her cheek I started freaking
out thinking it was she went outside and
got bit by something I wasn't sure what
was going on she acted like it was
really hurting her so brought her in she
had a pain in that blood right there
where there's smoke there's fire meaning
oftentimes we'll get presented animals
with a abscess on the top of the jaw
typically that means a bad tooth what
happened is there's a bacteria migration
from that tooth all the way up the
sinuses and it forms the abscess it can
be quite serious that plus pocket of
bacteria can travel all throughout the
body and cause kidney problems it can
make its way to the heart a simple
abscess can cause injuries that could
possibly be life-threatening what you
got going on with that man just a little
work you want to do some work over here
possibly look up here having a bad tooth
there probably let's put you up big girl
it happens one of my least favorite
things yep they can be tough sometimes
oh yeah knocking down yep
I am going to take that bad tip tooth
out we do a lot of things but Dentistry
is definitely one of the hardest things
it's definitely tough I just don't like
looking in miles I don't know how your
purse could be a dentist now we have to
be a animal dentist and they never brush
their teeth never ever so it's just
gross in there
gotta be an obstetrician pediatrician
Orthopedic gynecologist cardiologist and
a dentist and a dentist here it is Rana
janitor sometimes
hey sweetie we'll get you fixed up the
next thing you know you're waking up and
it's all over so this is the broken
tooth this tooth is chipped off and that
is causing the infection to get in so
we're gonna get this sucker out of here
I need my orange juice break this sucker
up these teeth have a lot of roots you
can't really just pull them out so what
we typically do is use some Rogers a
handheld tool that fits around the
groove of the tooth and we break those
teeth into pieces and once they're
broken into pieces you're able to start
drilling and then you take each root out
one piece at a time
actually we can break it up a little bit
that makes my mouth hurt let's see I got
a little piece in there okay I mean it's
in there pretty good yeah no two they
can be boogers man to get out
it is really difficult to get all this
tooth out if we leave just a small
portion that too then it can still be a
knowledge for infection and you can get
a plus pocket it could be a really big
big problem it took me in there boy
being a dentist is not an easy job
that is the root and the root is really
inflamed it's really decayed like it's
been eaten away the bacteria went around
and it goes up into the sinus cavity
still got a little bit of the root to
drill out sometimes they just they're
tough that Roots pretty bad here we come
there we go
you look like there looks really good
yeah I think that's good all right bro
wake her up good job bro sir all right
now we can just let this area drain and
everything's a success even though down
the street can be a little tough it's
very important part and if you're gonna
be a veterinarian you definitely have to
be a veterinarian dentist to make
everything successful hey
how are you baby I knew she'd have a
cone of shame on yeah so let's take a
feet this was a corporate that was the
bad too yeah and we actually got
stitches in so I closed it up so I'll
see you in 10 days and now I'm popping
those out and this right here well it's
raining on his own everything went
fantastic do you want to keep these as a
souvenir um I'll take a picture you sure
you know I put them zip like you want do
people do that yes no no it's okay
that's all yours enjoy I think it's a
great thing that they were able to go
ahead and take that out today to relieve
that pain from her pop-up adult can I
have my baby now
oh my baby she was in very good hands
today and I'm very very pleased with the
results that we've gotten so just to
make it through these next 10 days with
that cone on is going to be the
challenge I think you can't take it off
10 days yeah I know
you gotta go home you can't eat all my
grass man there's one thing that you did
that you know it's real cool what's that
and I don't know what the outcome was
the koi you removed the melanoma yeah
it's a deep melanoma that's how deep
that is yeah I'm just taking it off it
is doing so much better gorgeous fish
and you know they recognize how handsome
this fish was they even changed the name
from cure to guess what what Hodges oh
Lord
we had a very strange case of melanoma
cancer on the fish we named him here
after Dr Hodges did surgery on it and we
recently wanted to change cured's name
to Hodges as a thank you to Dr Hodges
and the critic fixers for helping us out
but Hodges has been doing great he's
just swimming around happy he has two
little friends him and his friend Paul
who are in the tank together his scar
looks to be healing the melanoma hasn't
grown back we're hoping to see some
scales soon but overall he is still
swimming well he's eating well and we're
really thankful that Dr Hodges could
come out take a look at him and make him
feel better we are really thankful for
the Critter fixers
oh I need to do the happy dance okay
does that work right there yeah I gotta
go side to side
hey hey how are we doing I'm fantastic
you know right yes sir so is that name
still lucky for now
Angela's husband brings lucky back to
Critter Fixer to make sure this rescued
bunny is healing and finally free of
maggots wow
much better a little bit better right
hey no matter it's a whole different
rabbit oh yeah it's a tough little bunny
man to be out there fending for herself
ears look a whole lot better hey letting
you touch them so what the kids think
about oh they love them they've adopted
them but we're just gonna go clean this
area okay we're gonna take these
stitches out get them fixed up give me
one second you got it thank you
wow lucky looks a whole lot better this
rabbit was full of maggots and big holes
and I was concerned I wasn't sure if
we'd live through this ordeal but the
area is starting to heal from the inside
out and it's starting to grain late I
think this rabbit is doing spectacular
I'm Blown Away wow your ears look a
whole lot better last time I touched
your ears you were all over the place
actually man you do it yeah it's
definitely always an amazing experience
when an animal that's been out in a
while and just having a fence for itself
and you know basically has no and now it
has a nice cozy home with kids to play
with is a good feeling it's a win-win
situation all around all right got that
fixed up take the stitches out man he's
a whole different one a lot stronger
though yeah yeah for sure and I got a
few more antibiotics for you to give we
should be good to go awesome so would
you expect me to have a bunny no
definitely not expecting to have a bunny
but in our house you never can tell what
you're gonna end up with so kids love
them well he's been awesome though Dr
Hodges done a great job you know we were
worried about the gas was just so big in
his leg we're worried about him being
able to move around and it's healed up
really well for him we're excited about
him being able to do his bunny things
appreciate it appreciate it thank you I
think what's next for Lucky he's just
going to give his best rabbit life with
the other animals we have and I think
he's adopted us so we'll take him in
another member of the family
[Music]